previously on
rafting we have eight sharks shut up why
are we cooking beef I'll kill you
it's actually okay that looks incredibly
unbalanced it's actually no no Miner
that it looks it's actually fine such a
rumbly machine clearly would be bolted
[Music]
did not do that
[Music]
yeah it's a less impactful harsh words
foreign
wait a minute wait a minute this looks
familiar mark this isn't a thing oh who
changed the number oh no no
no
no no we're only two kilometers away
guys I'll battle I'm battling as well
don't worry all right yeah let's do it
this is teamwork everybody oh one of
your crops
we're fine we're fine whoa there it is
there it is there it is something big
loaded in
it's huge are there bees oh is this the
one with the Bears yes
we're gonna be bees and bears buddies
for millions of years and bears the
bears and bees and all the other fleas
and fleas for use and Maze yes
that's what he said that place is a lot
bigger than I remember that's what she
said
[Music]
is everyone laughing about my thing
still yeah yeah we've been laughing at
your thing this whole time yeah that's
right that's right
mm-hmm
oh
it's dead
oh he's dead
oh Harvest it
no please not like this I'm paddling
paddling
oh God
uh wait I don't have a paddle Oh weird I
can see the bottom of the ocean
it's not a deep-seated fear that you
hold or anything hey guys I tried to
pick up everything and I'm full hmm
someone come pick up these piles of crap
that vomited out of me oh god
oh my god what happened what happened
problem
man as soon as I can make head stew I
can wait that's not wrong what then we
got space for wood wait this needs cream
there's a lot of wood guys I don't know
if we need any more wood I gotta be
honest I don't know if we do either
we'll eventually probably maybe maybe I
mean I really don't know I thought you
could put wood in the in the engine and
it would go but I guess I was wrong you
were wrong so wrong so wrong it sounds
wrong oh so wrong all right I guess
couldn't be more wrong all right
the wrongest
America
I said it slowly so it's not offensive I
still offended you know I've been
offended the whole time even if it's
slow what's breaking
Mark is axing things because of my anger
yeah
are we about to hit the island oh hey
Lando ah there it is I gotta say guys I
don't think this is the part of the
island we want to stop at the unscalable
cliffs doesn't look like the spot for us
hmm I'm gonna take us left I'm chopping
everyone
are we left
I'm going left are you are you turning
the sail away because that ain't how it
works no I'm paddling
oh then yeah we're left you put the lime
in the coconut don't call me a nut
[Laughter]
uh I said don't and if you're gonna do
it at least say it slow
not better
put the lime in the cocoa
um
do we thread that needle no no we
couldn't I'm I'm looking I'm looking oh
it'd be mad it would be Madness I'm
about to be out of paddle so that would
make us all out of paddle he's out of
paddle
I have a paddle he has a paddle you're a
magical
I could make a battle
dude I'm battling
oh you magic man I just tugged a random
wire that was hanging off my desk
hopefully my computer didn't die
probably fine
I uncrossed my legs and you know just
like my big toe caught on a wire and it
was like drinking I'm like that's
probably not important you mean you
don't have every wire that's anywhere
near your desk all in one big Loom
perfectly Ran So that nothing looks like
it's connected to anything yeah exactly
what because it would be so embarrassing
if you didn't have good wire management
yeah
yeah none of us know what that's like we
all have good wire management yes yes
I miss my desk and all the crap what I
used to have a hammock under my desk why
for your banana it was like 20 bucks and
it came with this certain desk that I
had and it was like or you could add it
on and I was like that might be cool and
I remember when I laid under it I was it
was very relaxing it was just like a
little cave how wide is your I mean I
guess you're not as I eventually tall as
I am but how big is your desk I have I
believe this desk is like uh a hundred
and something inches Jesus it's a it's
as wide as this room my entire day I'd
say enormous wait is that right
oh maybe oh it might be
it might be 96 inches I don't think it's
over 100. but either way it's it's very
wide
so I can lay under it and it's very
relaxing where's the Goddamn entrance to
this place I don't know apparently we
came from the wrong direction maybe it's
because we went back to the starting
point maybe we came from the wrong
direction
wrong direction a band yeah they're a
band they have uh plants left or
something see rotating smoothly
plants yeah wrong direction Lance you
know what I'm talking about don't
pretend like you don't know who wrong
direction is and what the whole Lance
drama is
Lance was it One Direction in Zane Zone
it's the wrong direction and Lance
oh
also somebody emptied one of these water
things and didn't fill it back up
Wade oh yeah I have always filled I
can't wait I have it marks water and it
feels good no still no water if all this
water up here for yourself and I think
there's a hammock underneath his pot
what are you doing up here oh you know
you know how it is
that why your pot desk is 6
feet wide yes what you said
no I mind it I mind it I'm minding he
did say it oh my God no no not the other
no not the other one ah that was close
that was really close everybody wow we
really stopped
it's weird we really don't go anywhere
how long have we been living with just
like slow movement oh game welcome to
round
we'll get this engine up and running
boys we'll probably need two by the time
we get it because honestly it's like one
per 100 tiles or something yeah we might
be just under that well I don't know
what the double decker
how that's I think it's actual footprint
not a number of tiles including vertical
but I'm not 100 sure so we build a
thousand tiles but just straight up it
would be fine I don't
don't don't
do it man don't do it hey Mark there's a
bird ah there's a bird
I missed
by that much I see kind of beachy this
does seem like it might be it
yay Wade can you oh it's it this is it
this is it wait steer us steer us into
the harbor oh which way I don't know
into it
oh
did we do it and straight
oh duh and that's not straight
and hand and right hard right right
right right right right right right
right
and straight straight straight straight
all right my battle broke and we're not
moving anymore because no one has any
paddles oh they're straight and we're
here
I crafted one
I'll just raise the anger then oh
straight straight straight straight
straight that's right we're turning
right really aggressively
[Applause]
all right
all right good done goodly done everyone
goodly done all right all right up on
the food beverage and [ __ ] let's
explore all right and what's this what's
that last one uh more beverages
I think that was it I think that's what
he said yeah oh okay all right let me
get some soup in me glug whoa my soup
food Bard grew yeah it grows dude bars
so big wait does it get bigger the more
soup you eat apparently
there's a Max I think but well I've got
it pretty big oh it's huge bar God damn
it's huge uh we might need an extra
spear before we leave because I think
there's a lot of bears do you guys have
nets for the bees uh I do not no we'll
leave the bees for you we'll take care
of the Bears for you I'm at the gates
he's at the gates
he's going beyond the gates shouldn't I
make a shovel
yeah I'll make a shovel do I need
anything to tame an aminal Bob I think
has the net launcher I don't have it
it's somewhere
unless it's not but I don't have the net
launcher I don't we made one see oh wait
I do see the net launcher oh and we need
to have net canisters which I know we
have at least two explosive powders
somewhere if we haven't used them
already no I saw them before
um yeah we'll worry about that when we
get to that if we see an animal we want
ah nah [ __ ] it I'll make it I'll make it
I'll just make it
[ __ ] it
the hell
uh standing still
oh excellent hey look a shark is
attacking where is it where is it where
is it where is it not that one go away
this [ __ ] uh unauthorized Personnel to
not enter during mating all the Bears
are [ __ ] well
well I understand why they're about to
be mad at us then yeah in the middle of
their [ __ ] time
okay I have net launcher [ __ ] 30 over
here I have two canisters for uh the net
launcher so yeah
all right I believe in you if if I miss
it's I don't get a second shot right I
won't miss I think it's just gone once
you missed I think I shant Miss I guess
we could have swam around to look for
more Blowfish but whatever it's fine
fine well across that fish when we blow
to it I'll be right there I'm still down
there yeah I'm just trying to like make
sure all the harvested is up and like
the shark you know
isn't gonna destroy our ship too much
I'm just gonna just as a precaution I'm
gonna build a ring around the engine
just in case I have a just this
nightmare thought that it's gonna go
around there and you know you know
okay so there's now a ring of protection
around the engine
that should be enough for us when we get
there and back
uh there's a bird eating your crops
[Laughter]
my car I don't have any crops right now
there's a bird eating something what are
you eating he's just chilling he's dumb
all right I'm coming
he's coming I'm coming he's past the
gates I'm past the gates
he's running up the hill I'm running up
the hill are you running up that road
yes here all right oh it's pretty
there's a path to the right and a path
straight I'm gonna check are we
splitting up or not splitting up yeah we
can split it go to the right okay you
guys go right there's a bear up there if
you guys gonna go fight that bear uh ice
oh there's a llama llama
I'm on a llama wait okay I don't know
how this Lancer works I'm just gonna try
three no no stop moving like that yeah
how do you get him to no no God no how
did this right it was right down here
Aidan missed he didn't miss it's fine
that's fine it was right on there
okay here we go a Crouch or something oh
yes oh got it
right oh my God canister left I have a
llama don't worry about it everyone I
have a life
or poison I will I don't know I think
yes yeah I can make a pen I can make a
pen
what are we going to name it
uh Lonnie mommy all right
l-a-m-i or l-a-m-m-i or Lamy with a Y
lamby Lammy maybe Lobby milkers
Lamy okay Lamy uh
we're milking it right what do we get
from llamas Lami milkers look I don't
want to be a complete a-hole but just
like
temporarily
I just got
no what'd you get biofuel refiner oh my
God yeah that's what we do all right
there we go Lamy
hi all right so that's good and now we
need grass plots for it does not die so
it cannot starve we need dirt Plank and
plastic okay
oh get away
um we need a light bulb and a hammer for
me to continue with this thing
I met like a big relay station I
parkoured over some poison water
uh
nothing nothing's going on uh-huh
I built him a house that's good yeah oh
he has a house oh God no how do I wander
the grass uh sprinkler we have a
sprinkler recipe oh you need a spring oh
I guess you do I don't know maybe
there's a watering can there's no water
in canned maybe just pour water with the
cup like we used to drink out of I think
that's what he's trying I'm trying yeah
it's not working though uh just do it
but better oh oh yeah he's right he's
right I'm at a relay station I have one
of three relay stations active it said
wow that was quick yeah but there's
still other stuff over here namely we
need a light bulb and we need a hammer
to unlock some secret thing I don't
remember where they are but I remember
you get the hammer from like the
campsite or something yeah
well they go over here whenever we get
them
well I think if I get hey what's up
giant bear uh-oh hey guys the bear you
remember the bear how the bear yeah the
bear yeah I remember the bear oh I don't
need to water it's raining I'm I'm dead
okay oh God I'm uh by the where the bear
is okay I'm gonna parkour back I was
pretty sure I could Harvest those
blueberries but that was a lie yeah that
didn't seem to go very good
oh this is lovely it's got grass Are You
Gonna Save Me he's got everything he
needs
hey I found a bear
nice Bob are you by this particular bear
I'm not really close to it but I'm in
that area for sure the area if you will
oh the bear found me
I I'm literally laying on the ground in
between where you came from and where
the bear is somewhere I'm coming no I
don't know where exactly you came here
I'm coming I'm coming fight the bear I'm
coming don't fight the bear I can't help
it the bear is fighting me where are you
did you go right wait I'm straight no
keep going the way we went marks
right and slightly left at some point
but basically straight all right I mean
left I see bear signs bear signs I
killed a bear you killed a bear
wow where I don't see uh here wait did
you kill the Bear by the blueberry
basket thing what do I see I see a tent
called Henry's stuff
well [ __ ] which which station did you
guys go towards I'm I'm lost I think I
did rain I think I did relay station two
is what I did okay I'll go that way I
think that's where I killed it
all right oh wait hey oh wow there you
are okay yeah right there I don't know
where the hell Bob is stuck oh
I'm on the beach by the boat now okay
I'll go down I'll run down there tubes I
need to drop off some [ __ ] oh never mind
now stay up
so you killed a bear that's really cool
um
I see Henry's stuff okay relay station
no Hammer there right it looks like
there should be a hammer there but I
don't think there is I don't see one you
went you said you went to relay station
too I think so because I came from the
right okay
ass face hey Bob hey what's up I hear
about that why do I hear a bell oh
that's scary where's our bike here
where's our bed at do we have a bed we
do have a bed right other side of the
body
there you go
oh shark no
of course it went right for the engine
that bastard of course it did all right
I'm trying to explore more I don't know
where I'm going exactly but I'm going
somewhere
Oh yay I thought you already researched
that
I found it I didn't research it ah I see
I see I see
oh I found Bruno's saw
bear does not like you getting Bruno saw
just definitely I have to fight it you
can't run away from it you have to fight
it you have to avoid it oh God okay
is this the bear you died to or
something oh man no but that's all the
Bears are the same
they're spawning
oh
this is gonna be a problem because my oh
man my spirit just broke
I
have trouble
Mark I found my own bear never mind
I have trouble
which way are you guys I can try to help
I'm just going I'm just running for now
but
I don't know how long I'll be able to
run hey another llama I killed the bear
just now
okay oh man I wish I had this beer can I
use my ass Maybe
I'm at the top of the knot done
drawbridge which I would drop if I could
take a second I'm at Henry stuff where'd
you go from Henry's stuff I don't know I
don't think I'm anywhere near there I
think I went up the mountain I'm trying
to like get a moment so I can
okay if I spear combat spear I don't
have anything oh I forgot I don't
actually have anything to craft we're
trying to find you buddy all right I'm
gonna I found bees up here too and
there's a llama I'm gonna try to lead
him down
the hill hey what's up oh that's waiting
me I'm sorry hey wait coming down the
hill down the hill where it's worth what
uh I I don't know I'm up the hill that
was towards the drawbridge I see like at
the where there's lockers and like tents
that's where I found the saw I'm coming
down the hill I'm gonna head there's a
sign I'm going towards relay station
two-ish
yeah I found a note
what's behind
we can't have that hey it's getting dark
yeah it's getting dark guys and your
flashlight's on hey wait the beer's gun
we must be punished the Bear's gonna
hold [ __ ] ton of notes up here wait I
think I see the drawbridge I know yeah
the bear just disappeared I'm gonna head
back
we probably want to kill the Bears
because they do give leather I got a
light bulb guys oh we need that relay
station I think it's really station two
oh hell the dummy outside that needs it
up the stairs I'm behind somebody
not me uh oh there you are come on
follow me hey I'm about to solve me and
my half a spear are here to kill a bear
well the Bear's gone thankfully how did
I find in my own area that no one else
is what happened to me I don't know
nice whoa that almost crushed me all
right what is this place oh uh wait I
found bees if you go the opposite
direction of this drawbridge there was
bees over in the other area don't know
if you found that yet
I have not I've not found any yet but
I'm gonna I'll look around while you
explore the building you think there'd
be bees up here too I thought there were
lots of bees of these islands maybe
there's not they've changed I remember
there being kind of a lot yeah
look balanced things for gameplay
reasons
[Music]
that sounds terrible fuel pipe
what is that for oh I know what that's
for yeah the kids are fighting oh I
found bees hell yeah Bruno's Hammer got
hammer
two of three relay stations are active
right now it says up here
I just want to talk this Miranda is
screaming outside
I found Honeycombs but no actual bees
ah there were some flying around there
it might be because it's dark or
something I don't know yeah we need like
uh one more relay station Bob did you
put the light in the other relay station
yet no I haven't found it yet okay so
this one's I'm currently fighting a bear
and there are bees over here where I'm
fighting the bear oh son of a [ __ ] oh I
lost my spear oh there it is
I haven't made extras like a smart I
didn't know it would be so much combat
there if you could stop falling down a
hill so you could let me collect your
meat okay oh my God he's shaking his ass
at me oh my God you see any bees up on
this hill I've only seen the honeycomb
oh not here over this way
I got bees over here by me yeah Wade
follow me follow me to the bees I'll
show you
if I pick up Stones can I make like a
stone can I use a stone as a weapon
can't you make like a stone spear oh you
can't you can throw it you can throw
rocks
you could totally throw rocks rocks are
weapons
wait a minute have rocks always been
weapons they're bees bees bees you see
the bees go get the bees all right you
guys have to be as I was at because I'm
so lost right now no these are different
bees don't no we're on the other side of
the Island from you I think you don't
know where I am all right is there a
bear by your bees though because there's
a bear by those bees no there's no bears
by these bees I don't see any bears how
do I get the bees to come down they're
so hot you got it good luck
okay relay station six okay I got stung
by bees I didn't know they could do that
oh they'll get you
I hear some bear noises is that Bob is
that you fighting a bear you hear me
murdering a bear that's me I hear
something
what let me pick your ass up
you can pick my ass
no
harsh no
ah nice and soft all right and I accept
it I gotta go through this spooky cave
to be never mind
what I have 10 B jars and 15 Honeycombs
at the moment what do I need a goddamn
machete to get through this crap what is
what
more hey ass face
look at this do you have a machete I
don't have a machete
ax doesn't work uh I don't have a
machete yeah I don't know what that's
about how do we get a machete I don't
know there must be a machete around this
island somewhere
well boobies
left with the hammer and I went up I
found you for five seconds and then
where'd you go well I'm gonna try to get
up climb the mountain I'm trying to
exploit my way up
oh okay seems like maybe they don't want
people to do this but I'm going to try
hmm
oh wait I know I do see you wait I'm
coming back it's quite impossible over
there I was trying to go hello where I
came from that's where you came from how
did you get what do you even came from I
came from I climbed up from this way
weird I could not if you go over here
see
well there's somewhere on this island
that's like a machete and I don't know
why a machete works better I'm the
hammer and the light bulbs and people go
back to relay too we can uh turn them in
and like opens up something oh you guys
didn't even go to relay too I never
found it originally Oh Come here boy
wait if you look over there that
outcropping straight across from us on
top of there is a bear and some bees
okay well I'm gonna go I'm gonna go
relay too and I'm gonna do it without oh
right I remember what the berries are
for you put the berries in the Big
Barrel and it draws the incredible wait
don't
oh this way
oh I was just peeking hey what is that
bear should we help with this Bear real
quick yeah maybe we should help kill
this Bear yeah oh yeah you see that it
did not like that
oh these rocks I'm out of rocks man I
really should go get some stuff from the
boat first I'm about to go down Lads oh
God I'll get you I got you I needed to
go anyway wait you gotta go down wait
you got it I'm about to go down wait oh
God Mark uh maybe just hide me somewhere
and then get weighed away from the bear
yeah let me I'll pop you there
uh Wade
what happened I'm sure it's fine uh I
barely didn't get it
all right hey guys how's it going
putting you down
uh where's the boat
uh-huh that's not I thought this was the
boat and we're on the far side of the
Island from the boat I think ah
interesting okay well Wayne you'll
unstuck when the time comes uh I will
get around this bear don't worry yes
yeah
man you know
I like the way you grunt
I said I feel like you're mocking me
uh you do not make that sound sorry yeah
what makes you think that's you that
next time I don't know it was timed up
to every jump I made and I was like I
was very confused oh you're jumping
constantly I know but it was really
timed up to it for me uh-huh it really
seemed like I I mean everything was just
a stretching mark because yesterday was
shoulders okay
all right somehow on shoulder date I
hurt my thumb it doesn't make any sense
all right wait do you need me to come
back for you because I'll do it I don't
have it unstuck yet all right let me
grab something he'll unstuck let me grab
some Stones the best weapon anybody's
ever known Time Craft up your food water
I would never Spears I would never maybe
I'll get an unstuck Chance by then oh
God wait is that a well all right all
right I'm coming
all right oh Jesus so glad you came all
this way never leave you behind I would
never leave you behind thanks man all
right I'm gonna go on a stone throwing
Adventure I need to craft the new spear
before I go back to fight a giant bear
I think that's [ __ ] word wait is there
more soup I need to steal more soup
upstairs he's actually I probably will
just try to get to relay station too I
don't see soup upstairs he's there
should be unless someone took all the
soupsies I think I took the last one he
took the last oopsies oh wait are there
bowls Wade oh yeah there's uh there is a
clay Bowl yeah there's soup up in here I
feel like you know do we drink the soup
and then smash the bowl on the ground
because I feel like they should recycle
the bull okay the soup is so good that
you take a drink and then you spike the
bowl into the ground aggressively yeah
it's like whereas Guardians
huh you know that was Thor did and we
don't know if like the first four movies
he would smashed like his drink after
drinking or whatever yeah you did that I
remember is it yeah he did that
I don't like DC movies so
I'm really uh hammering this this oh man
it takes nine rocks to nine or so rocks
to kill a bear
wow in case you were curious how do I
think we have a lot of rocks how do I
meet up a bear how do I get the bear
meat
hold e on his ass it's just really
tricky he's not on his ass straight ass
you have to like find The Sweet Spot the
Bears hitbox is really bad all right
well it is uh
he's still jiggling
he might just be knocked out I might
have just unconscioused him oh can you
can you knock him out without killing
him I don't know I hit him with a bunch
of rocks and he went down so I'm
assuming maybe either way I dealt with
him
let me reload my rocks
can you get them back after you throw
them no they break just like Bulls oh
the Honeycombs and the bee jars here
just in case why are there why are there
so many spikes here
why is it radioactive here
relay too do you have to parkour over
the barrels and boxes and [ __ ] uh I'm
not going to I'm gonna go around
oh maybe it's impassable it's impassable
you do have to parkour
it's almost like I've been there okay
I hope I don't die
so there's a dummy outside you need to
put the light bulb in and there's a
shelf inside to the right you need to
put the hammer on huh
I feel like it was the Big Bear I don't
know to the left if you go up the hill
and then Lefty Lou
okay hey look I find the place hey wait
a minute how'd you get here
did you parkour
yeah I may have just climbed up the
mountain did you did you parkour
use one Bruno's Hammer all right
Bruno's wrench Bruno saw
we don't have the wrench
um damn it
damn it it's fine
I'm guessing you already activated uh
station two yeah yes if that's the one I
was yeah I did all right never mind this
was all a big waste of time I bet that
big bear is guarding it
oh wait no we
we cave okay oh yeah that sounds right
that sounds right what cave you know the
cave
no I really don't all right I found a
bear but I don't think it's the bears
but I think I can fight this bear the
bear was next to the cave Mark where'd
you go I'm going towards the bear
me too where's that it's uh
think the way I'm going but is I went
basically when we go up the whoa it's
here oh it's big yeah this is it
this is it guys I killed a bear watch
this
put berries in the
the tub got the berries in the tub
it's going to eat the berries and then
I'm gonna go around it and I'm gonna go
in yes it's going to eat the berries it
is eating the berries this is excellent
I'm in the cave perfect
there's dirt in here there's mushrooms
a crate yeah I got it Bob are you still
in that Ranger Station no I'm not uh
[ __ ]
we can research machete this is perfect
now I go back
to the boat and then I'll be able to get
a machete and then we'll be able to get
through those Vines we'll activate the
last relay station then we'll get the
hell out of here
oh my God it's a perfect plan which
relay station do we not have six
okay it's uh through the vines which I
believe is up that mountain that you
climbed Bob oh that you climbed all
funny we need to build Honeycombs like
on the boat right like that's the thing
we do we build like a honey box or a bee
box or something uh yes I I did the
nasty parkour I'm back at the place
where the wrench goes okay I'm learning
machete oh I have a machete
in my inventory why do I have three
Spears in my inventory what oh I picked
it up from a crate I think okay well
that's helpful for bear fighting I guess
I could have gone straight there for the
machete all right I'm coming back I
guess I'm in a house you're in a house
oh I'm in the house where the wrench
goes oh okay all right you stay right
there I'm almost uh to where I should be
I think I'm not going anywhere this is
my house now all right good what are you
guys doing on my Island this is my
Island uh uh
I mean I don't know I don't know how I
get here Mark watch out on that hill
behind you watch out in your face behind
you oh
God Mark watch out for that mountain you
jumped off of it's fine it's fine the
Bear's still
[Music]
I found it guys I hit the right button
first try
oh my God the timing
wow I'm really glad I decided to go on
this adventure with you to this place
where you need the machete wait oh
you're here wow how long have you been
here a while since I said look out
behind you on that mountain I didn't
what
have you been here
long time now all right whatever Bob are
you ready you ready you ready for your
glorious purpose
yep you're ready I'm ready okay I know
you said it the one time I was like
hoping for like a rule of Threes like
are you ready and then you get crazy
reached it's a bear
wait you got it yeah oh my spear broke
hey Mark I need a distraction
distraction that's too late for me it's
too late for you sorry I'm in you it's
too late for you
oh God mark huh what's up
distraction it's uh too late for uh any
of us why is this not working I feel
like red this machete should be working
wrench literally there's a Nikon that
says machete
for to me to machete oh I was too close
to it all right Wade you got it
all right good job wait
great how do I get to you down keep
following this path yeah keep following
the path go in the cave
there's a cave there's a cave
most certainly is a cave hey a note okay
wrench in common
in a minute okay get ready on that
wrench I've been ready all right hold on
there's a note that's not a wrench hold
on wrench incoming
uh-huh branch is almost here are you
ready for the range
give me some noise for the ranch
get a wrench
there's also a dude up here
the wrench
got me a note oh
uh Johnny is here I think we all have to
touch Johnny for him to join us oh no I
don't think we all have to touch Johnny
why would we all have to touch Johnny is
that if you did it he didn't unlock for
me it's not there yet mark look at all
this dirt here Johnny's talking
bears are not cuddly
see where are you guys you can go to the
boat now I think we're gonna be done
here in a second and we need to turn on
a relay station or something I did
oh yeah yeah the the number is 4988
sorry
new playable character playable
character yeah
Johnny oh
okay that was a mistake I'm fine all
right yeah I found more bees would I
would I win hey I'm here for Johnny all
right we should leave all this plastic
did you want to play Hello bear oh God
I'm coming Bob wherever you are I will
find you
nice shortcut is there a shortcut oh if
I I'm gonna fall and die I'm gonna fall
and die I'm gonna fall